[Applause]
this was behind the defense horde you
can't find him
lamelo eyes everywhere left-handed pass
to rozier
dribble right on the money this pass
right here
half a look away
[Applause]
lamelo straight to the 10.
[Applause]
no resistance
two for one mode i guess lamelo leaves
it for pj
all swirls
good win right to ball
[Applause]
caleb made one a moment ago
wants to have a conversation
mellow in the air but he finds number 10
who's up and down
good
atlanta get pretty good looks from three
only eight of 22. oh lamela ball
every which way but loose his second
field goal
this right oh my goodness herder has
been in a
couple of underneath the basket
and miles bridges comes away with it
lamelo on the run
hayward with two knows how hands oh
it he wanted to throw the ally the
series against the hornets
so good at the look he can make that but
it's not a good shot when you're not in
rhythm he's over three three of ten for
the game
lamelo that's a good
[Applause]
sees where he needs to deliver it
and the rhythm dribble between the legs
lamello sneaks inside and
scores at the rim really good at
protecting the ball
through traffic look how he protects it
right there
still gets it up oh he came down on his
left ankle hunter
lamelo bullet past pj sneaks it past
capella
[Applause]
lamello finds hayward
gordon hayward the veteran
another assist for lavello see if
somebody can get hot
offensively for the hornets lamelo hung
in the air long enough to get it to pj
about you score and a lay-up on the
offensive end of the floor nice hang
right there about
lamelo to get into pj and the hawks come
right back at you
get to the free-throw line but he's
played starter minutes now that
bogdanovic
has not come out of the locker room here
in the second half
lamelo easy left-handed layup
miles bridges working the baseline
lamelo
challenges capella and wins the battle
seven perfect from the three look at him
inching his way toward that triple
double
13 points eight rebounds nine assists
how are you partners i've seen him love
and
line him up throw it in let's have a
ball
barrett next game new york
lamello got it he's got
19 points off the play he's out for the
season with acl
yeah tough break for him finally found a
home in orlando
lamella bully ball get out of the way
trey young oh right there it knows trae
young
oh good too small caleb martin miles
bridges sits
pj there it is if that ruled an assist
that's number 10 for lavello ball and
he's got a triple-double
come on it's 2021. that's the nba
it is an assistant congratulations
lamelo ball
now the youngest player in nba history
with a triple-double
and that's a real triple-double 21
points 10 rebounds 10 assists only took
10 games
[Applause]
fresh screen right there right down the
middle one little dribble to get to his
spot pj
does lamelo ball the favor
tough shot